en ce dimanche puis septembre séjour de
mariage à coup remet un mariage en tenue
solognote du début du xxème siècle qui
rassemble des dizaines de bénévoles
enthousiastes on accepte de jouer ce
rôle d'une part bat pour mettre un
village en valeur c'est mon village
donc c'est important en fait de réunir
les gens d'avoir une convivialité et
puis de faire la fête tous ensemble pour
se souvenir aussi qu'on est tous
solognot et qu'on a un patrimoine d'une
richesse historique
on doit aussi qu'on se doit de faire
perdurer cette noce est en fait la
reconstitution d'un événement réel qui
s'est déroulée dans ce même village de
cours main en octobre 1904 les
organisateurs de berling berdoyes on
travaillait avec le groupe de recherches
archéologiques et historiques de sologne
pour retrouver des témoignages de ce
mariage plus que centenaire une noce
exceptionnellement immortalisée par une
série de cartes postales
j'en ai découvert dans ma belle famille
deux clichés ces deux là et puis j'ai
cherché à savoir on m'a dit c'est court
mais vin et j'ai cherché à savoir et
j'ai retrouvé une carte postale ou une
femme dit reconnaître le mariage pona si
le nom de la jeune fille nous nous
sommes retrouvés elle avait vu les
cartes postales à blois
nous avons été désagréablement surprise
ne se retrouve en photo et puis surtout
avec des légendes qui des fois jeunes
filles ont costume de fête ou alors
jeune paysanne hubei solognote donc ça
leur plaisait pas le sieur faisant
ernest luiz silva henry cent quinze ans
plus tard la noce de cours demain a été
bien plus photographiés que celle de
et restera elle aussi dans les mémoires
des solognots du 21e siècle